ein durchbruch auf den die fachleute am
versuchsreaktor jet im britischen cullum
seit 25 jahren hin gefiebert haben in
einem experiment gelang es einen energie
impuls von 59 megajoule freizusetzen der
bisherige wert konnte verdoppelt werden
vor allem für das europäische
großprojekt etat ist das eine gelungene
generalprobe
doch wann kann dass staaten kriegs um
science and future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen am jet
fusionsreaktor in der nähe von oxford
konto nun mehr energie durch kernfusion
erzeugt werden als je zuvor an diesem
ort mehrfach hatten wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler in experimenten eine
kernfusion mit der terium tritium
gezündet und dabei 59 megajoule an
fusionsenergie freigesetzt und das ist
ein neuer rekord für diesen reaktor denn
der bisherige rekordwert aus dem jahr
1997 beträgt nur
21,7 megajoule laut den fachleuten vor
ort hielt der plasma puls für fünf
sekunden und das experiment wird als
großer erfolg gefeiert denn das ganze
wird als eine gelungene generalprobe für
das europäische großprojekt etat gesehen
wie genau lief das experiment ab und
warum ist das so wichtig für die
europäische kernfusionsforschung sind
wir einem erster kern fusionskraftwerk
also näher als gedacht die antworten auf
all diese fragen und noch viel mehr gibt
es jetzt hier von mir bei pixum future
nun mal vorab trotz dieser großen
fortschritte wird es noch geraume zeit
dauern bis die kernfusion realität wird
aber sie wird die erneuerbaren energien
in einigen jahrzehnten ablösen können
das wird jetzt immer klarer und das wird
dann eine zukunft ohne energie sorgen
denn kernfusion funktioniert nach dem
großen vorbild der sonne hier
verschmelzen einer dauer reaktion
wasserstoff atomkerne zu helium quasi
das gegenteil zur kernspaltung wie sie
in atomkraftwerken genutzt wird das
große ziel ist es die kernfusion durch
menschenhand zu realisieren denn ein
kern fusionskraftwerk auf der erde
könnte eine menge an energie produzieren
und zwar umweltverträglichen sauberen
strom und das ohne von wind sonne öl
oder gas abhängig zu sein und bei einem
unfall werden keine riesigen region
unbewohnbar ein super gau mit vielen
toten kann es dort nicht geben ein
erheblicher teil des globalen
energiebedarfs könnte in zukunft also in
weiterer zukunft also durch
fusionsreaktoren gedeckt werden
vollkommen ungefährlich die menschheit
könnte so also zumindest in der theorie
eine unerschöpfliche energiequelle
erschließen doch bislang scheitert es an
der bilanz bei allen bisherigen
versuchen zur kernfusion ist die
erzeugte energie geringer als die
eingesetzte energie die technik dahinter
ist eine riesige herausforderung denn
damit wasserstoff atome zu helium
verschmelzen muss die elektrische
abstoßung der atomkerne überwunden
werden dazu muss das gas extrem erhitzt
werden wodurch es zu einer diffusen
wolke aus durcheinander fliegenden
atomkernen und elektronen kommt in der
fachsprache ist vom plasma die rede das
plasma fängt an zu brennen wenn genügend
teilchen oft und heftig genug
zusammenstoßen 100 millionen grad und
eine plasma dichte von etwa 100
millionen teilchen pro kubikzentimeter
sind dafür notwendig wobei das produkt
dieser beiden größten entscheidend ist
die energiebilanz ist bei bisherigen
kernfusion experimenten also im minus
gewesen doch in den vergangenen monaten
häuften sich die erfolgsmeldung nicht
nur aus der wissenschaft selbst sondern
auch aus dem privaten sektor
mittlerweile sind auch einige start ups
mit großem ehrgeiz dabei kommerzielle
reaktoren zu entwickeln diese könnten
zum teil schon ende des jahrzehnts in
betrieb genommen werden schon oft hieß
es aus der forschung dass die
fusionsenergie bald reif sei doch in den
entsprechenden kreisen ist das bereits
ein geläufiger scherz dann nachlegen
fusionskraftwerke immer 30 jahre in der
zukunft zahlreiche forschungsteams und
gründerinnen und gründer sind sich
mittlerweile sicher dass uns die
fusionsenergie deutlich näher ist als
wir bisher alle dachten nur wann das
scheint trotzdem er in der fernen
zukunft zu liegen der joint european
torus jet wurde bereits zu verdrängen
sich im betrieb genommen und um das
aktuelle ergebnis zu erzielen hat es
fast 40 jahre gedauert sein
nachfolgeprojekt in der fusionsforschung
ist der internationale thermonukleare
experimenteller reaktor kita der derzeit
in südfrankreich gebaut wird jet selbst
gilt als zu klein um netto energie zu
gewinnen dennoch ist er für die
europäische fusionsforschung wichtig den
jet gilt als der derzeit einzige
fusionsreaktor der stabile kernfusion
mit deuterium tritium betreiben kann
jetzt wurden die spannenden ergebnisse
der aktuellen experimente veröffentlicht
die bereits ende des vergangenen jahres
stattfanden für den jet selbst sind die
erzeugten 16 kilowattstunden
fusionsenergie in fünf sekunden ein
neuer rekord es ist extrem wenig energie
so viel verbraucht ein elektroherd
ungefähr in zwei stunden aber es handelt
sich um die zweite große fusions
kampagne von jet und es wird wohl auch
die letzte bleiben der letzte rekord aus
der ersten kampagne lag bei etwa 6
kilowattstunden in derselben zeit auch
wenn es in den vergangenen jahren viele
neue entwicklungen gab der bau des
reaktors liegt schon fast ein halbes
jahrhundert zurück und das ist auch der
grund für die kurze betriebsdauer denn
es sind kupferspule die das magnetfeld
von jet erzeugen und der elektrische
widerstand der kupferdrähte führt dazu
dass sich die spulen stark aufheizen der
betrieb ist also nur für wenige sekunden
möglich bei modernen supraleitenden
magnetspulen gibt es in der
betriebsdauer kaum begrenzung und so war
auch nie als ein ziel ausgeschrieben
worden dass durch die neue jacksons
kampagne neue rekorde gebrochen werden
die nun erreichten 16 kilowattstunden
erzeugt dafür dass energie
entsprechenden modellierten annahmen den
beteiligten forschen mann war darauf aus
daten und erfahrungen zu sammeln die
beim bau und betrieb des internets ich
sein können sie soll in drei jahren im
jahr 2025 das erste mal ein plasma
erzeugt werden so der bisherige plan
doch wahrscheinlich wird es eher 2035
zehn jahre verzögerung 23 jahre nach dem
baubeginn symptomatisch für die
entwicklung der kernfusion erstens
dauert immer alles länger um zweitens
als man denkt der etat ist mit
supraleitenden magneten ausgestattet und
die forscher sind sich sicher dass sie
auch die magische break even grenze bei
der energieerzeugung gebrochen werden
kann zum vergleich im chat musste drei
mal mehr energie in die reaktion
gesteckt werden als herausgeholt werden
kann beim etat soll das genau
andersherum laufen das ziel 500 megawatt
energie ausbeute über mindestens 300
sekunden zehnmal mehr energieausbeute
würde so gewonnen werden als das
hineingesteckt werden muss in der
letzten stufe soll etat also krasse 500
megawatt fusions leistung erzeugen aber
nicht nur der fusions leistungswert beim
sich ist von großer bedeutung sondern
vor allem auch das verhältnis der
fusions leistung zur externen
heizleistungen diesem kontext wichtig
der sogenannte crew werthein verstärkung
faktor für ein wirtschaftlich
funktionierendes kraftwerk müsste wohl
zumindest ein q faktor von 20 erreicht
werden oder ein brennendes plasma in
einem brennenden plasma nämlich gibt die
fusionsreaktion wärme ins plasma ab eine
äußere heizung ist damit nicht mehr
notwendig der kuh faktor ist zu
vernachlässigen class aber auch die
bisherigen reaktoren sind weit von
diesen zielen entfernt doch inter soll
die machbarkeit der fusionsenergie
demonstrieren und bezeugen sowohl
technologisch als auch wissenschaftlich
gesehen dafür sind china die europäische
union in den japan südkorea russland und
die usa mit am start die kosten des
reaktors liegen bei mehr als 20
milliarden euro dennoch ist jet in
seiner heutigen form ein modell für etat
dass daten aus möglichst vergleichbaren
bedingungen liefern kann von der
magnetfeldstärke und der große mal
abgesehen die betriebszeit von fünf
sekunden war nach ansicht der fachleute
lang genug um rückschlüsse auf einen
dauerbetrieb zu ermöglichen wenn das
plasma wurde in den jet experimenten in
den fünf sekunden etwa zehn mal komplett
ausgetauscht der grund dafür seien 3,5
tesla starkes magnetfeld reicht
lediglich dafür aus die plasma teilchen
durchschnittlich für nur rund eine halbe
sekunde einzuschließen deshalb müssen
dauerhaften neue partikel eingeschossen
und aufgeheizt werden die einschuss zeit
beim mieter dagegen wird rund vier
sekunden lang sein bedingt durch seine
größe und dem starken magnetfeld heißt
also hier muss im verhältnis viel
weniger plasma eingestellt aufgeheizt
werden die energiebilanz wird hier also
deutlich besser sein technisch gesehen
basiert etat auf dem töpfermarkt
anziehen der begriff zocker mark heißt
übersetzt übrigens so viel wie toro
ideale kammer in magnetspulen wobei
dieser betrag auf strom hindeutet und
somit die besonderheit des talker markt
prinzips hervorhebt den stromfluss im
plasma das magnetfeld wird hier zum teil
von einem in plasma fließenden strom
erzeugt das konzept beim töpfermarkt
basiert also auf dem magnetischen
einschluss charakteristisch bei diesem
projekt ist ein reifen förmiger
magnetfeld käfig der das plasma deutlich
länger zusammen halten soll so soll die
sogenannte energie einschluss zeit
optimiert werden und hier ist er laut
ansicht vieler fachleute auf einem
wirklich guten weg allein schon wegen
seines enormen plasma volumens von
achtung 8 140 kubikmetern damit ist da
im verhältnis vom volumen zur oberfläche
absoluter spitzenreiter wissen wir ja
aus dem matheunterricht umso größer das
volumen desto kleiner ist die oberfläche
im verhältnis zum volumen so sollen
verlust prozesse so gering wie möglich
gehalten werden eine entscheidende frage
aber genau in zahlreichen projekten
geklärt werden muss dreht sich um die
beschaffenheit der reaktor wende
schnelle energiereiche neutronen werden
bei der fusion frei und stellen einen
großteil der energie aus der funktion da
in den jet experimenten wurde nun
erstmals beryllium als beschichtung
verwendet und zudem ein die wärter mit
wolfram überzogen beide komponenten
arbeiten so wie zuvor in den
modellberechnungen vorhergesagt die
forschungsteams vor ort jedenfalls sind
von der sache überzeugt so auch die
wissenschaftlerin attila kappa tour die
am jet experiment beteiligt ist in einem
interview mit spiegel online sie sagt
die fusion dauert aber die arbeit lohnt
sich wir haben auch keine andere wahl
die fusion ist unsere einzige option
wenn wir klimaneutral sein trotzdem
zugriff auf saubere konstanz verfügbare
schier unerschöpfliche energie haben
wollen wir müssen das machen jetzt wow
und es gibt noch mehr projekte
kernfusion für zu hause wie soll das
gehen dafür hier anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren das geht mit dem abo button
unter jedem video ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran